many years ago this young man said let's
do a vlog I was like ok this is episode
400 what's a blog like calling you blog
by the way what's a vlog I'm just not
romantic about anything that happened
yesterday 90% of people default into
looking behind them instead of looking
ahead of them
understand that you're asking to live a
top 1% life in a seven point seven
billion person world people's fears are
predicated on other people stop looking
for Commission so I just don't
understand why people are living their
lives like that most of all nothing's
gonna happen unless you do something
please if you then wrap your head around
what you're actually aspiring to do like
[Music]
[ __ ] in a super macro like I'd much
rather be me than this [ __ ] ugly
green carpet play until I die you know
and that's why I can see when somebody
likes it no matter what the [ __ ] it is
you never get to cash out and buy the
Lambo the game is the [ __ ] Lambo once
you love the game whatever that is you
win the whirlwind vlog I didn't Rob it
I'm just trying to make it more binary
for people which is are you happy or you
not right and if you're not why life's
about choices brother who the hell's
permission are you looking forward to do
your thing like thing yourself out ask
that person out quit that [ __ ]
[ __ ] job the punchline is
self-awareness man I'm not gonna tell
them go do this I don't know them I
don't know you do you you know you stop
being scared of who you are if you love
it so much then you want to be here so
you don't love it enough to [ __ ] back
please get another [ __ ] job at the
brass man that grass is green as [ __ ] on
everybody else's lawn in the
decisiveness
not doing anything about it it's just
not an option the hard work is the most
controllable stop asking for permission
I got [ __ ] on for not being the wine guy
anymore when I started talking about
business until I did it I am stunned by
how many people have the ambition and
their mouth is running to what they're
gonna accomplish and their actions don't
map to it at all
you know just either gonna will yourself
to victory or not mindset of execution
clouds and [ __ ] dirt [ __ ]
clouds and dirt maybe this year the
moment that you finally make 2018 a year
when you start living your [ __ ] life
and how much you mean right now 15 grand
I'm in I'm sorry what I'll pay for the
whole thing [ __ ] out of here the problem
is in entrepreneurship especially modern
day entrepreneurship we do not celebrate
the game we're putting the riches on a
pedestal I don't think people have
really audited how much downtime they
have if they want it tired what happens
when you stay curious and humble is you
start listening when you start listening
and executing it allows you to have the
audacity to start talking that is a good
strategy I feel what I lose or things
don't go my way that I truly deserve it
if I'm gonna enjoy the fruits of the
victories I have to learn from the
things that I [ __ ] up on you have to
respect the game more than you respect
yourself I sit here and I say have
nothing to lose and the person watching
on YouTube right now is like the Flexi
tong enough there's so much stuff I
don't anything that we lose because the
stuff is not what I'm playing for people
get too fancy they buy an expensive car
in the second home and now they're stuck
because they have a mortgage and I have
to pay for those things I don't say this
stuff in theory does not theory for me
it's not intellectual this is practical
reality
everybody talks about content right what
content what content with content
nobody's talking about community it's
about the other
man run the marathon not the sprint I've
realized what's going on here one life I
realize that I'm living like this is our
only at-bat and most of you aren't
everybody's just like trying to close on
the first move and it never works not in
the long term negativity and and tactics
win in the short term positivity and
merit and the stake win in the long term
you're just not patient like if you're
feeling any angst it's because you don't
love the process more than the results
you're thinking about $10,000 a month in
Adsense instead of loving the [ __ ]
dirt like once you let the math take
over the art you're dead yeah like the
soul has to come first you have to be
thoughtful exactly you can't just throw
it up there and be like uh but if it
ever Trump's the soul
you lose this becomes available when you
become great at something like this the
problem for everybody right here is
they're trying to do all this before
they got great at this patience [ __ ]
patience well then all of a sudden all
the [ __ ] that comes along with it
makes a hell of a lot more sense
everybody just thinks they're entitled
to it it's about leaving money on the
table in the short term my friend things
problem is so many of you sell [ __ ] you
don't believe in you're just doing it
for the [ __ ] money you're gonna
[ __ ] news and that it'll like I think
that people don't understand how much
they're gonna regret when they're older
are you self-aware enough of what kind
of founder or entrepreneur are you I
don't like when people think I'm a
futurist or or disruptor
I don't think I am I actually think all
I am is just very practical and do you
know how to surround yourself with the
things that you need to be successful
instead of blindly thinking you can do
everything just a very grateful for the
life I'm living
more importantly for the attention that
you guys give me and so I hope you have
a wonderful day
this shit's binary either a good person
or a bad person if you got talent you
don't if you're a good person you got
talent you win through the other part
you lost everybody is trying to mitigate
risk
and hedge against vulnerabilities I run
into them I run right the [ __ ] into them
of binary it's truth or it's not in
hip-hop that I'm obsessed with not gonna
do the right thing everybody's worried
about themselves best way to worry about
yourselves is to do for other people
Shane I'm gonna fly you to New York City
to vaynermedia and you're gonna spend a
day with me and my team I promise we'll
hit its practical [ __ ] whoa don't lie
everything I say is gonna happen to me
it happens let's go high-low [ __ ] the
middle so that's what it is though the
middle is where everybody's losing slow
it down pick one do it for a year and
then adjust like that's where
everybody's losing there's just nothing
like the beginning of building a [ __ ]
monster if you don't love it for the
loving it and it's about the money
you've lost I want to build the biggest
building in town ever by just building
the biggest building in town while I
think most people try to tear down
everybody else's building so I think
positivity and good is practical advice
to building an empire if you've got it
like that you gotta go you gotta go
I feel like I'm open source
entrepreneurship I'm free I'm putting
out my best [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm like yes
and I can leave and go [ __ ] and fly to
LA right now
because the next three hours is yes you
can't stop winners from winning my
friends and then you can educate the
other 99% and get all the admiration and
leave a wonderful legacy and live a
fulfilled life that's the model it
should be rock doing the right thing was
always the right thing always and
forever
nobody is putting on marathon sneakers
everybody wants to be a sprinter
everybody wants it tomorrow it's the
grind it's the message it's doing the
right thing embrace the chip on your
shoulder and and expand on it and triple
down on it and and really use it to your
advantage we're going to work harder
than the next guy take more pain in the
next person just don't stop [ __ ] and
don't quit that's it and if you're not
doing that you're gonna finish second or
third just when you're in your [ __ ]
zone when you're doing your thing you're
not scared of anything even being in the
middle of the road just walking at it
you're just not [ __ ] scared
I'm just feeling great and I wish you
the ability to be in your [ __ ] zone
our ambition to be great is driving this
whole thing we're just all cliques you
understand all the variables you know
all the moves
it's the reps you've seen it before
you've seen it before you've seen it
before that's where I'm at
it's one [ __ ] at Rebecca thank you
she's gonna sit you're welcome
episode 400 I hope you enjoyed it you
rock just put this in my face and want
me to close it out I don't have anything
to say I'll see you in episode 500
[Music]
i'ma get my